le ministre irakien des affaires
étrangères a longuement commenté le
sujet du retrait progressif des troupes
américaines de son pays depuis le début
du dialogue stratégique entre washington
et bagdad
le nombre de soldats us est passé à
l'entendre de 5200 à 2500 à l'heure
actuelle et dans un avenir proche ce
chiffre passera admissibles l'occasion
pour sergueï lavrov de faire un
parallèle avec ce qu'il s'est passé en
libye où ce qui se passe actuellement en
syrie où les états unis sont présents
militairement sans l'autorisation des
autorités du pays les choses sérieuses
nov si les ingérences des américains et
de leurs alliés
que ce soit en irak en syrie ou en libye
n'a pas amélioré la vie dans ces pays
certes elle n'a fait que créer des
problèmes que les citoyens les hommes
politiques et les dirigeants de ces pays
doivent maintenant surmonter ces péages
octobre
bien sûr il est crucial que les
dirigeants américains évitent ce genre
d' aventure à l'avenir surtout des
aventures qui représente de grave menace
pour la région tout entière jouent gros
ce là et en disant cela le ministre
russe des affaires étrangères pense bien
évidemment la présence de soldats
américains dans le nord-est de la syrie
et même si donald trump on a rappelé une
partie en 2019
il en reste encore plusieurs centaines
sur le sol syrien
cette déclaration est également un
message pour le prochain président des
états unis
en effet les intentions de joe biden
dans la région sont encore peu claires
même s'il a suggéré que le dossier
syrien ne faisait pas partie de ses
priorités
étant donné qu'il dit vouloir dans un
premier temps se concentrer sur des
problématiques de politique intérieure